-Welcome back. They love you.
-Wow! [ Laughs ]
-Come on!
-I'm, like, blushing.
-I know! Come on.
Welcome back to the show.
Thanks for coming on.
I appreciate this.
We have so much to talk about.
First of all, congratulations.
You're married.
-I am, yes.
-This is fantastic!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How does it feel?
I met your husband.
-Yeah, you did! You met Bader.
-I met him backstage.
How does it feel?
Are you...?
-It's great.
I mean, it's amazing.
I met my person.
You never know if you're gonna
find that in life,
and he's an amazing guy, man,
and I love him,
and we're a great team.
-I'm so happy for you.
How long have you been married?
-We've been married since April.
-Yeah.
-April 3rd.
-I love it. Does it give you
a whole new perspective on life?
And you go, "Oh, yeah," you have
a buddy now that you can...
-You just get to share
everything with someone.
And it's so special.
Everything becomes that much
more important, I feel like.
-I always wanted to tell you,
by the way,
I listened to your podcast.
-Yeah.
-"The Lohdown."
And you're very good.
I mean, are you...
Usually, you're on the other
side getting interviewed.
But do you like
interviewing people?
-I was so nervous when I did
my first interview.
Because I'm used to getting
the questions asked to me.
I'm not used to asking
the questions.
-But you're good at it.
-Well, I got good at it.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, the first...
I can't even watch the first --
-I was, like, sweating
the first one.
You can't see that
on the podcast, but...
-Oh, I can't watch
my first "Late Night."
I can't even look at it.
I'm like...
-I think I was here for that.
-I think you were here
the first week.
Thank you for doing that.
I was stuttering.
I was flop-sweating.
It was rough. It was rough.
-And now look.
-Well, congrats.
Yeah, now look. Yeah.
Can we talk about
"Falling for Christmas"?
-Yeah.
-It's on Netflix.
This is my type of movie,
by the way.
I told you backstage,
I'm so into these movies,
these holiday movies.
I want "Love, Actually"
every day of the year.
Yeah, that's what I want.
-That's my Christmas choice too.
-That's what I want
all the time.
But let's -- can we set up
what this one's about?
-So, it's a girl
who kind of is an heiress
that has pretty much everything
and something happens to her,
she gets in a bad accident
and she gets amnesia
and remembers nothing.
-Yep.
-And I think
it's a beautiful story
because it's about how we always
want more things in life
but the simple things really
mean the most to us in the end.
And that really --
I connected with that.
I love that.
-It's gonna crush.
I'm so happy.
-And it's really funny.
I do a lot of physical comedy
in it, which was fun for me.
-Yeah, and you sing in it,
by the way.
-I do, yeah.
-Can we talk about this?
'Cause -- no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love your voice.
We want more singing.
But the song of choice
is "Jingle Bell Rock."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, let me...
Let me remind
anyone who doesn't know,
but the last time you sang
"Jingle Bell Rock" in a movie
was in...
[ Audience cheers ]
..."Mean Girls.
[ Cheering continues ]
How --
-Thank you!
How did it come about?
Whose idea was it to do
"Jingle Bell Rock"?
-Well, it was a joke, actually.
I was kidding around
with the producers
and the director,
and I was like,
"Oh, it would be great
to do, you know, like,
a 'Jingle Bell Rock' skit."
And I -- I shouldn't
have said it,
because they went straight to,
"Oh, let's re-create
the 'Mean Girls'
talent show scene."
I was like, "Oh, no, no.
You can't touch 'Mean Girls.'"
Sorry, that's like...
You can't do that.
[ Laughs ]
So then they were like,
"Oh, can you do the song?"
And so I was like,
gotta do the song.
-Yeah, you got to give them
what they want.
Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everyone's loving it.
-I hope everyone likes it.
-Ah, it's perfect
for the holidays.
There was also --
I saw recently,
Jamie Lee Curtis was being
interviewed and they said,
"Would you ever want to do
a 'Freaky Friday' sequel?'
or something, and she said,
"I have a great idea for it
and I talked to" --
I think she said
she talked to you
or pitched you an idea.
-We did speak about it, yeah.
-And is there any truth to --
is it moving forward?
Or is anyone --
-First of all,
let's just take the fact
that I was on set
filming at the time,
and Jamie Lee Curtis writes you,
and you just get excited
and distracted immediately.
-Of course.
-So, I had to bring myself
down to earth and be like,
"Okay, I'm on set,
I have to focus."
And then she said
"Freaky Friday 2,"
and I got more excited.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, but then also the fans
were like, "Wait, this is good."
And the idea for the plot
was good, too.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, it is.
-Which, so -- yeah.
But I mean, is there anyone --
-We would both be into it.
-You would?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get on this.
-I'm not gonna say no to Disney.
-Let's make this into a thing.
[ Applause ]
Any "Mean Girls 2"?
-I think that's
in Tina Fey's hands.
-Okay, okay.
-And Lorne Michaels.
-Tina, I know you're watching.
Yeah, let's make that happen,
as well.
I want to show everyone a clip,
though, of your new movie
right now,
"Falling for Christmas."
Take a look at this.
-We just ran out
of pumpkin pancakes,
but if you'd like,
I can make you some eggs.
-Oh, please.
I'm perfectly capable
of making my own breakfast.
♪♪
It's broken.
-Yeah, no, you just gotta...
You gotta push it in
and then twist it.
-Thank you.
Oh! This comes out fast.
-Egg?
-Thank you.
-Oh!
Well, you showed that egg
who's boss.
-[ Chuckles ] A little messy.
-You know what? Um...
Why don't you sit over there,
and I will take care of...
all of this.
-Okay. Good idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
I love Olivia.
-Olivia Perez.
-Olivia Perez. I love her!
What a great actress.
So cute.
Lindsay Lohan, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Falling for Christmas"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Lindsay and I are doing
something fun
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.